[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous
une menace existentielle pour la terre
et les hommes
voilà l'alertent lancé par l'onu il ya
quelques mois
l'air catastrophé qui prédit que nous
avons deux ans pour agir contre le
réchauffement climatique
sinon nous allons subir des conséquences
désastreuses et irréversible
agir
c'est à dire se questionner et changer
ses pratiques
son mode de vie son mode de consommation
sa façon de travailler de voyager
alors merci à l'onu on les avait pas
attendu mais mieux vaut tard que jamais
constater que nous vivions dans une
société absurde
absurde pourquoi nous avons déjà perdu
60% de notre biodiversité
800 millions de personnes vivent avec
seulement 1 dollar 90 par jour
14% des français sont sous le seuil de
pauvreté
face à ces constats il ya déjà une
dynamique mondiale des femmes et des
hommes qui propose des solutions
concrètes pour changer le paradigme de
la société contemporaine
en france c'est 10 % du pib
10% cela représente la valeur créée par
ses militants ses lattes ses salariés
des associations des coopératives des
fondations des entrepreneurs sociaux
ce sont les chevilles ouvrières de ce
qu'on appelle l'économie sociale et
solidaire
une économie responsable et vertueuse
j'ai de la chance moi je les connais
bien les entrepreneurs sociaux puisque
je suis dirigeante de la ruche pas celle
qui dit oui la ruche incubateur
nous sommes un réseau d'incubateurs qui
accompagne depuis dix ans
des entrepreneurs à concilier business
pipeau une planète
affaire l'humain et les ressources
on de façon très joyeuse parce que nous
nous retrouvons dans une communauté de
pensée professionnels et bienveillante
ok 10% face à la menace existentielle
c'est pas mal
paraît pas assez
dans cette alerte le nul nous appelle
également nous la société civile a
demandé des comptes aux grands patrons
fait pression sur les dirigeants hockey
challenge
en effet il faut changer nos industries
c'est une évidence
il faut changer les multinationales
et ce soir moi je voudrais vous partagez
un constat que j'ai pu refaire sur ces
grands patrons
ces grandes patronnes ces grands
dirigeants dirigeante tous ceux et
celles qui font tourner cette grande
machine qui disons le
broie la planète creuse les inégalités
et en plus très souvent ne rend pas très
heureux
ce que j'ai pu constater c'est que pour
que cette menace existentielle elle soit
efficace c'est-à-dire qu'elles induisent
un changement dans les pratiques
il faut que la menace elle pèse non pas
sur la planète
un peu vague mais sur eux mêmes sur leur
personne
combien de fois on peut entendre des
discours
d'avant j'avais des grandes
responsabilités avant je gagnais
beaucoup d'argent avant je passais ma
vie dans des avions
et puis dans cette ville un
bouleversement un pépin
souvent un cancer voire un burnout la
perte d'un être cher
un revers de fortune un moment qui n'est
jamais rigolo
à partir de ce moment tragique qu'il se
sont questionnés et qu'ils ont tout fait
différemment
des affaires qui l'ont recruté
différemment qu'ils ont été différents
à partir de cette étape de vie ils sont
passés de désengager a engagé
vous allez partager le constat c'est
quand même dommage d'attendre d'avoir un
pépin de vie pour s'engager pour se
mobiliser
est ce que les mots sens comme un
intérêt général
humanité
à ces deux sens
est ce que les chiffres ne sont ils pas
assez alarmant
ou bien même à ce que le pépin du voisin
son expérience est pas assez équivoque
pour se mobiliser
ce qui est d'autant plus dommage
c'est que je suis sûr que ces personnes
va les appeler les reconverti
ap
sur déjà en eux ce sentiment que quelque
chose ne tourner pas rond
quand y regarder des photos du continent
plastique de la déforestation ou
simplement en croisant le de nombreux
sdf dans la rue
ce petit sentiment qui fait qu'on s'est
à païta ils ont attendu un grand pépin
pour que ça se transforme en révolte
alors moi ce soir je voudrais aussi
faire un appel
un appel à la jeunesse
parce que vous allez faire tourner
l'économie de demain matin
je vous propose que vous ayez le déclic
tout de suite que vous vous engagiez
maintenant
que vous laissiez grandir cette révolte
si le déclic
est liée à la peur de la mort
l'éphémérité de la vie on n'a qu'à se le
dire vie de ce soir
oui il ya un moment on va tous mourir
allez on passe à l'étape 2 et on
s'engage
soyons une génération engagée des
professionnels militants
dans cet appel je ne vous demande
surtout pas de faire des sacrifices
je ne demande pas de faire des choix de
carrière qui ferait grincer les dents de
papa maman
ce que je vous propose c'est de
construire une solution une économie de
solutions responsables une économie dans
laquelle nous faisons carrière nous
mettons du sens
nous pouvons chacun de nous venons
exploiter nos talents nos potentiels
et ça en respectant l'environnement
magnifique
c'est déjà possible
on peut travailler dans une entreprise
qui allie sociale et business
tu regardes sa chaîne
d'approvisionnement a pris
approvisionnement sa chaîne de
production
cerise sur le gâteau elle paye même ses
impôts au bon endroit
et si vous avez envie d'être
entrepreneur d'être start peur c'est
possible aussi
il existe des entreprises à un pacte il
existe des start up qui lève des fonds
qui sont vertueuses et un succès
et dans cet engagement jours
pause qu'on essaye de ne pas faire que
notre part nous ne soyons pas que des
colibris
la légende du colibri elle raconte que
face à un instant dit dans une forêt
chaque par contre
et que le petit colibri qui ne peut
faire que du goutte à goutte
peu inspirés et mobiliser les autres
membres de la forêt et permettre
d'éteindre l'incendié
c'est très beau
mais si nous ne sommes que 10% à faire
notre part je suis pas sûr qu'on arrive
à enrayer la menace existentielle voyons
plus grands
déjà on part du principe qu'on sait pas
on n'est pas des colibris nous sommes
des canadair soyons ambitieux oui
faisons des choix professionnels mais
inscrivons aussi cet engagement dans
notre quotidien
à commencer par exemple par notre porte
monnaie
c'est bientôt noël
disait que sous sapin on mettait que des
cadeaux
écolo
aux responsables fairtrade que des
cadeaux qu'ils respectent la planète et
les hommes qui les ont fait et ça peut
même être jolie je vous jure
éthique et agréable
faisons notre part mais aussi celle de
notre voisin
parce que si dans un autre temps
certains n'avaient fait que leur part je
ne suis pas sûr par exemple que la
résistance se soient organisées
nous avons deux ans
deux ans pour agir
deux ans pour passer de 10% à 100%
engagé
moi j'y crois et vous
[Applaudissements]